madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans cette
édition un deuxième suspect interpellé
dans la sphère du meurtre du petit
adrien après les aveux hier d'un
marginal deux hommes vont être mis en
examen contre l'utilisation des mines
antipersonnel l'émirat les pyramides de
l'indignation des montagnes de
chaussures dans une douzaine de villes
en france à l'appel d'handicap
international à la veille des élections
en allemagne les derniers sondages
donnent un léger avantage à gerhard
schröder sur le chancelier helmut kohl
dernier meeting de campagne
bercy affiche complet pour la grande
fête du rail 1 2 3 soleil en pleine
lumière les talents réunis de rachida
khaled et faudel que nous retrouvons en
direct à quelques minutes de leur entrée
en scène
khaled sera l'invité de cette édition et
puis nous retrouverons également direct
de tel-aviv yannick noah pour ses adieux
je vous le disais en titre à thionville
l'enquète s'accélère à un deuxième homme
serait impliqué dans le meurtre du petit
adrien après les aveux hier d'un
marginal de 36 ans tout à l'heure le
substitut du procureur a indiqué que les
deux hommes vont être mis en examen pour
homicide volontaire sur mineur reportage
jérôme soûlard patrice chômage heures 17
heures cet après midi très escorté le
visage caché deux suspects et non un
seul sont enfin présentés au parquet de
thionville
alex e 36 ans nicolas 28 sont en garde à
vue depuis 48 heures les soupçons qui
pèsent contre ces deux hommes semblent
cette fois très sérieux
les deux individus l'un d'eux me rends à
thionville et l'autre à hayange sont
présentées actuellement au magistrat
instructeur en vue de leur mise en
examen du chef d'homicides volontaires
sur un mineur de 15 ans j'ai requis
mandat de dépôt à leur encontre
trois mois et demi après la disparition
d'adrien la maman de la victime veut
aujourd'hui des réponses à ces questions
bien difficile ont même à tout vent n'a
pas cessé de voir surtout ses effets
recèle bon de voir les personnes déjà si
c'est que déjà en premier pour savoir
est-ce que j'ai connaissez ou est-ce que
je les ai déjà vus lambda moselle tête
devant un liddell que je les voyais déjà
bon après battlelore demande idée savoir
pourquoi ils ont fait ça les agresseurs
présumés vivait effectivement à
thionville à 50 mètres à peine du
commissariat alex loux et même une
chambre au café de la lune depuis un an
un homosexuel divorce et que personne
ici n'avaient jamais soupçonnée ce
monsieur est tout à fait discret ça fait
un an qu'ils habitent là et il a une
très bonne allure même à côté un peu je
dirais à la fois jovial mais timide et
il ne fréquentait pas mon débit de
boissons les deux hommes interpellés
sont actuellement entendus par le juge
d'instruction au palais de justice de
thionville
si le premier suspect alex 36 ans semble
avoir déjà avoué son crime à la police
le 2e nicolas 28 ans nie pour l'instant
tout en bloc
les auditions devraient donc se
poursuivre une bonne partie de la nuit à
bruxelles cérémonie ce matin en hommage
à la jeune semira morte par étouffement
mardi dernier pendant son expulsion
plusieurs milliers de personnes se sont
retrouvées devant la cathédrale saint
michel
alors que ce soir on attend la décision
du ministre de l'intérieur qui doit
confirmer ou non sa démission
caroline marie patry gurs tom
dans la cathédrale saint-michel celle
des cérémonies royales
la dépouille de la jeune semira adamu la
mer
elle aimait la liberté
des témoignages des prières des chants
l'hommage de tous ceux que la mort de la
jeune nigériane a bouleversé
m
sur la place près de 5000 personnes se
sont rassemblées elles forment qu'un
cortège silencieux qui se transforme
rapidement en manifestations de colère
remonte à la 11 parce que c'était moi la
merde au nom des ses murailles connu
mais y en a des centaines d'autres
je suis véritablement en tant que belge
révolte est honteux d'être belge
aujourd'hui je trouve ça absolument
scandaleux et c'était prévisible mais
sans papiers les associations de défense
des droits de l'homme tous dénoncent les
méthodes policières et les textes qui
les réglementent pour séduire est
inscrite dans la loi elle était
naturelle régulière c'est scandaleux
la gendarmerie belge a présenté ses
profondes excuses et ses sincères
condoléances à la famille de samira à
dany quant au ministre de l'intérieur
louis tobback
il devrait dire ce soir s'il reste au
gouvernement ou s'ils démissionnent
contre la fabrication et l'utilisation
des mines antipersonnel des pyramides de
chaussures se sont élevées depuis ce
matin dans une douzaine de villes de
france 4e édition de cette manifestation
organisée par handicap international
reportage ce film est l frédéric basket
depuis ce matin les paires de chaussures
s'amoncellent mocassins chaussons ou
godillon en vrac forme ces montagnes
érigée en symbole strasbourg marseille
ou paris 12 villes au total ont répondu
à l'appel de handicap international
si certains se sentent peut-être plus
concernés que d'autres mais supporterait
plus pourtant ça fait plusieurs années
que je viens me suis toujours aussi lu
chacun vient ici modestement témoigné
son horreur contre ces engins de malheur
les mines antipersonnel
quand ça explose ça fait quoi
ce combat souvent anonymes a touché une
dizaine de cinéastes regroupées sous la
houlette de bertrand tavernier dix
courts métrages pour choquer les
consciences et je me suis contenté de
vomir vos tellement et dans tout le
monde qui me choque c'est une arme de
l'arche sont des gens qui ne prennent
pas leurs responsabilités sont des
gouvernements qui ne prennent pas leurs
responsabilités sont des industriels qui
ne prennent pas leurs responsabilités
c'est normal de dénoncer ça le prix
nobel de la paix est venu couronner l'an
dernier le travail des associations
contre la barbarie des mines et cet
après midi c'est le président de la
république jacques chirac qui recevait à
l'elysée les représentants de handicap
international pour saluer leur travail
remarquable
demain ces milliers de chaussures seront
triés puis redistribués aux plus démunis
pour que rien ne se perd et ses
manifestations viennent soutenir
l'effort de ces pays qui ont ratifié le
traité d'interdiction d'ottawa les
signataires s'engagent à cesser la
production et l'utilisation des mines
antipersonnel mais le chemin est encore
long aujourd'hui on dénombre plus de 60
millions de mines enfouies ici ou là
patrice romedenne jean louis normandin
des signatures comme celle ci il y en a
130 au bas du traité d'interdiction des
mines antipersonnel mais pour que le
traité d'ottawa rentrer en vigueur il
fallait que 40 états le ratifient c'est
désormais chose faite quarante pays donc
certains engagements sont symboliques
celui du vatican celui de l'île maurice
par exemple d'autres le sont moins
la bosnie le zimbabwe tous ces pays
doivent cesser la production
l'utilisation et l'exportation de mines
ceux qui disposent de stocks quatre ans
pour les détruire ainsi la france
propriétaire d'un million 400 mille
mines la moitié aura été détruites avant
la fin de l'année le reste le sera avant
l'an 2000 selon une histoire de la
défense un grand absent qui refuse de
signer le traité avant 2006 les états
unis la raison officielle c'est la corée
les états unis veulent continuer à
pouvoir utiliser des mines parce que ils
disent que ça défend leurs soldats en
corée
la raison qui est derrière elle et plus
économique c'est parce que les états
unis ont des systèmes de minage mixte
antipersonnel et antichars interdire les
mines antipersonnel serré ça veut dire
qu'on m'interdit toutes leurs armes de
protection et c'est ça leur pose un vrai
problème
les organisations non gouvernementales
déplorent aussi le double jeu de
certains pays signataires du traité
d'ottawa via les rapports clair
aujourd'hui que de nouvelles mines sont
posés en angola au soudan au sénégal en
particulier en casamance au cambodge
le problème c'est que les gouvernements
ont du mal à contrôler qui pose ses
mines est ce que c'est des troupes
gouvernementales et cdc des troupes
rebelles
le sol de la planète est truffé de 60
millions de mines une estimation
vingt mille victimes chaque année les
plus chanceuses s'en tire avec une
prothèse
en attendant le déminage qui ne prendra
pas moins de dix ans dans les écoles du
cambodge où d'ailleurs on apprend à
vivre avec la mort sous les pieds
il n'est juste pas joué aujourd'hui sa
visite officielle en chine il a quitté
shanghai pour hong kong le bilan de ces
journées positif le premier ministre se
dit confiant dans l'évolution
démocratique de la chine et plaide pour
une réforme du système monétaire
international roland sicard bernard
connor à shanghaï
on peut trouver à peu près tous y
compris des gens qui parlent le français
car même si l'anglais est de loin la
première langue étrangère des classes de
français existe la bonne volonté
lionel jospin était venu en classe pour
écouter et pour encourager comme
l'anglais sera utilisé par tous c'est
une langue qui sera malmené et qui
perdra sa beauté originelle
je vous conseille de choisir le français
défense du français à shanghai
mais quelques heures plus tard il a
fallu s'adapter il faut dire que c'était
à hong kong colonie britannique rendue à
la chine l'année dernière
hong kong frappé de plein fouet par la
crise financière asiatique et d and
gentlemen lionel jospin il ya défendu
les mérites de l'euro en anglais avant
de revenir aux français constatons que
dans la crise financière qui s'est
produite dans son étape asiatique ou
dans sa phase russe l'euro même
simplement comme une perspective proche
et pas encore comme une réalité à jouer
un rôle de stabilisation
pas de spéculation sur les monnaies
européennes est au contraire une
capacité à résister à la boîte lionel
jospin qui aura beaucoup parler
d'économie mais qui aura aussi fait de
la politique on ne manquons jamais de
citer le nom d'un français qui vient
souvent en asie
jacques chirac car si le premier
ministre veut parfaire son image
internationale
il veut aussi éviter des polémiques et
ménager les susceptibilités les règles
de la cohabitation s'impose aussi à
l'étranger
en france le gouvernement a décidé de
suspendre leur déploiement des forces de
police et de gendarmerie
un projet qui avait suscité ces derniers
mois réprobation et inquiétude ce
redéploiement devait toucher une
quarantaine de communes
passant de la responsabilité de la
gendarmerie sous celle de la police
reportage dans l'une de ces régions où
devait s'appliquer cette nouvelle
répartition
muriel la saga gilbert usant l'ombre des
policiers plane encore sur la ville de
mazamet pour combien de temps la réponse
reste pour l'instant en suspens malgré
l'annoncé faite par le gouvernement de
geler le plan de redéploiement
les policiers ne désarment pas la
nouvelle a été dans l'ensemble de bien
accueilli mais comme les com en a
signalé aux collègues il faut rester
mobilisé quand même et auprès des élus
locaux également pour savoir le devenir
finale de ceux de ce dossier mais un
samedi coincées à agrandir et et puis
j'étais pas absolument
il ya eu ainsi voulu au début pour un
désintéressement un peu au mois de mai
puis progressivement il ya une prise de
conscience sur toute la population qui
maintenant se rend compte du problème
parce qu'on savait les pétitions
circulent encore car dans cette bataille
mazamet risque de perdre son
commissariat et ses 42 policiers comme
193 autres communes
la peur d'un avenir sans police est
devenue préoccupante on se sentirait en
somme comme si nous étions des avants
dans les deux d'une mère voilà en somme
c'est ça je trouve que c'est dramatique
il faut absolument
un commissaire
et un commissariat
la face à de si vives réactions
manifester par tous l'ancien ministre de
l'intérieur paul quilès avait lui même
demandé il y a deux jours l'arrêt du
projet gouvernemental
les vaut mieux revoir la copie c'est la
décision la plus sage me semble-t-il
encore une fois revoir la copie ne veut
pas dire revenir sur les objectifs qui
sont de bons objectifs et et j'y adhère
ce redéploiement va désormais faire
l'objet d'une consultation approfondie
les policiers ont ainsi démontré qu'il
ne faut jamais trop voler dans les
plumes d'un pool et en allemagne les
derniers sondages publiés aujourd'hui
confirment à léger avantage à gerhard
schröder sur le chancelier helmut kohl
bien sûr rien n'est encore joué et c'est
sur le terrain hier pour les derniers
meetings que les deux leaders ont conclu
leur campagne
la maille ans l'autre à berlin olivier
lerner et philippe rochot s'il a choisi
berlin pour son dernier meeting
ce n'est pas par hasard c'est dans cette
ville redevenu capitale politique que
s'installera dans le courant de l'année
prochaine
celui qui dirigera la république pendant
quatre ans
c'est sans se lier du 21ème siècle qui
passera le cap de l'an demi à berlin
gerhard schröder imagine bien que ce ne
peut être que lui il a tout fait pour
arriver à la veille de cette élection
avec un profil de gagnants mais qui est
tendue et les gars ont été soigneusement
évitées
moi j'hésite encore entre les verts et
la gauche mais je vais le changement ça
c'est sûr que nous avions laissé seul et
manquera donc toutes les cartes en main
pour s'imposer
46e et dernier discours devant 9
personnes une mécanique parfaitement
rodé helmut kohl en prend pour son grade
c'est l'homme du passé dit il le
chancelier du showmatch pas d'effet
d'annoncé spectaculaire
les électeurs sont plus appelés à
départager deux hommes que de programmes
assez similaire en fin de compte 50
meeting en un mois pour helmut kohl qui
n'a rien perdu de sa combativité il a
voulu conclure sa campagne à mayence sur
les bords du rhin sa région natale et il
était fier de voir que la jeunesse était
aussi venu l'applaudir et l'à beaucoup
fait pour la main et l'a découvert la
réunification
helmut kohl part de la réforme des
impôts du kosovo de l'europe
les candidats non ce que le chômage est
passé sous la barre des 4 millions des
opposants contestent
car parmi les vingt mille personnes qui
assistaient à ce rassemblement il n'y
avait pas que des partisans
les sociaux démocrates les communistes
étaient là aussi mais le football a
condamné d'avancé toute alliance que
pourraient faire les socialistes avec
les verts ou les rouges si la gauche
devait gagner la vraie décision at il
dit à ses électeurs c'est de continuer
avec nous en direct de bonnes nous
retrouvons olivier lerner au delà des
programmes des différents partis le
choix des électeurs se portera bien sûr
sur les deux hommes candidats à la
chancellerie avec d'un côté helmut kohl
68 ans 16 ans de chancelleries derrière
lui catholique pratiquant chrétien
démocrate il incarne à lui tout seul la
continuité
cette stabilité que qui plaît tant aux
allemands il brigue donc un cinquième
mandat et vers signé pour quatre ans de
l'autre côté c'est l'inconnu un nouveau
visage c'est gerhard schröder 54 ans
d'origine modeste protestants il est à
la tête du land de basse saxe du côté de
hanovre depuis les années 90 il a fait
la course en tête dans les sondages
depuis qu'il s'est lancé dans cette
bataille
kohlschreiber ces deux styles deux
générations différentes aussi l'un a
connu la guerre l'autre pas et c'est
devant ce choix que vont se retrouver
les 60 millions d'électeurs allemands
appelés aux urnes demain la longévité
d'helmut kohl a finalement c'est
finalement retourné contre lui c'est
presque aujourd'hui devenu un handicap
il arrive en fin de carrière et livre
quoi qu'il arrive son dernier combat
si le spd devant la ddt cd ou demain et
bien cela voudra dire que les allemands
ont fermement mais poliment demandé à
rennes redoutent qu'al de tirer sa
révérence eh bien nous verrons demain à
l'évidence l'un des grands thèmes de
cette campagne aura été l'emploi et
notamment les 35 heures deux conceptions
qui s'affrontent les chrétiens
démocrates du chancelier kohl préconise
plus de flexibilité alors que le parti
de gerhard schröder
réclame un pacte pour l'emploi l'exemple
de ses minces à berlin reportage chez
les pros chaud et pierre moscovitch
werner fait partie des 300 mille
ouvriers des usines siemens et
travaillent ici à la fabrication des
conducteurs haute tension à 42 ans il a
déjà passé la moitié de sa vie chez
siemens une grande famille capable de
prendre en charge les gens de la
naissance à la mort c'est dans cet
esprit que la firme est à la pointe de
la flexibilité du temps de travail et du
dialogue permanent avec le patronat
parfois il y a des délais très serrés de
production mais quand il ya moins de
pression on peut convertir les heures
supplémentaires en temps libre je
travaille 9 heures par jour dans la
semaine et la semaine suivante je reste
trois jours à la maison un système bien
acceptée car ici le problème des 35
heures est déjà dépassé les syndicats
ont accepté des accords salariaux modéré
et la réduction des coûts du travail
incite à l' embauche la possibilité de
travailler 50 heures par semaine mais
aussi 25
la responsabilité en incombe à chaque
employé lui même lit c'est une décision
commune sur le volume du travail qui est
présente concertation avec l'entreprise
werner vite ainsi au rythme de la
production tout comme il vit dans
l'univers de siemens qui lui propose de
logements un trois pièces à 5000 francs
par mois
la flexibilité du temps de travail lui
permet de mieux profiter des loisirs
offerts par l'entreprise
j'ai plus de temps libre je peux décider
moi même si je commence à 6 heures à 8
heures si par exemple j'amène les
enfants à la maternelle
car au travail pour lutter mais
l'univers deux hymnes stadt la ville de
siemens à berlin où logent 18 mille
ouvriers n'est pas forcément enviable
alors pour 2000 francs par an werner
loup à siemens bien sur un lopin de
terre à deux pas de son logement pour
occuper les loisirs que lui laisse la
flexibilité de ses horaires de travail
depuis cette information qui nous
parvient à l'instant le ministre belge
de l'intérieur louis tobback maintient
sa démission
et ce en dépit des pressions du 1er mai
str pour qu'il reste voici cette
information donc qui vient de nous
parvenir
retour en france à aurillac l'escapade
de quatre adolescents au milieu de la
nuit de jeudi à vendredi a tourné au
drame
une adolescente a été tué et un autre
grièvement blessé en tombant d'une
falaise falaise située près du gîte
rural où les lycéens qui est en classe
verte les accompagnateurs ont été
entendus reportage parce qu'elle nous
c'est bon valérie cryptant l'endroit est
aussi beau que dangereux la falaise de
lits à 12d indiqué sur aucun panneau
aucun chemin public ne mène à son sommet
d'ailleurs ses victimes dans soupçonnait
certainement pas l'existence jeudi la
soirée se termine est agréablement pour
ces élèves de première le lycée
professionnel d'aurillac les avait
envoyés là pour construire la cohésion
de leur groupe en début d'année scolaire
peu après une heure du matin myriam et
nicolas 17 ans quitte le gîte pour
chercher un peu d'intimité mais le prêt
à 100 mètres de la maison est un piège
vous et répond qu ils donnent
directement sur la falaise dans sa chute
myriam est certainement morte sur le
coup nicolas lui est tombé en la
cherchant comme deux autres camarades
aujourd'hui
leurs jours ne sont plus en danger reste
à savoir comment ils ont pu échapper à
la surveillance des adultes
le fait que certains élèves soient déjà
couché et d'autres pas encore à
faciliter effectivement l'escapade une
partie du groupe avait passé la soirée
au café le plus proche
il est possible mais pas encore certains
effectivement que que certains d'aidé
scolaire était un peu un peu plus sous
l'emprise de l'alcool
les investigations sont loin d'être
terminées quant à l'éducation nationale
elle a diligenté immédiatement une
enquête administrative
la surveillante et l'enseignant qui
encadraient le groupe sans ressorti
libre hier soir après quelques heures de
garde à vue
en fait seul nicolas le petit ami denis
rien ne peut expliquer en détail ce qui
s'est passé cette nuit là mais son
audition n'a pas été possible pour
l'instant pour raisons médicales
quant aux résultats de l'autopsié de la
jeune fille ils ne seront pas connus
avant mardi soir le mariage réussi de la
science et de l'image à l'initiative du
cnrs l'une des plus grande manifestation
mondiale qui réunit chercheurs
professionnels des médias et grand
public
la tour eiffel depuis aujourd'hui
patrice pollet frédéric basket c'est
l'impressionnante balade d'un trou noir
dans l'espace pour la première fois la
visualisation d'un édifice il a qu'en
france que l'image scientifique restitue
par le film scientifique
et sert à expliquer
ici une étude par des chercheurs sur le
crâne de joseph merrick elephant man qui
a vraiment existé
grâce à ce long métrage on découvre ces
visages inconnus qui font progresser la
science le film explique aussi le
travail d'une équipe
aujourd'hui les chercheurs sont parvenus
à un très haut niveau dans la mise en
scène de leurs travaux ils ont l'oeil du
professionnel un scientifique est un bon
cinéaste
c'est par un grand signal ça peut être
un grand cinéaste mais c'est un bon
cinéaste à condition d'avoir je me fais
des films de famille d'abord je me suis
baigné un mariage d'une première
communion parce qu'il sait tout de suite
trouvé l'angle de prise de vue le cadre
depuis les années 60 da des premiers
films scientifiques
l'engouement du public pour ce genre n'a
cessé de croître alors aujourd'hui le
chercheur est devenu un héros un sauveur
qui va même jusqu'à être mise en scène
pour cautionner les grosses productions
de l'industrie
indiana jones jurassic park dans la vie
d'autres un autre exemple urgence
urgence et une série une des grandes
séries populaires
notre télévision aux états unis cela a
rempli les universités en médecine en
france ça commence à 6
la future station spatiale est déjà
terminée grâce au film scientifique
virtuelle qui permet aussi d'accélérer
le temps
et d'apercevoir toute une vie
en quelques secondes
la pluie a quelque peu gâché la fête des
rollers 2000 d'entre eux se sont quand
même rassemblé à paris costumes et pour
certains ils ont défilé dans les
quartiers de la capitale
on attendait 15 mille adeptes c'est dire
l'engouement pour ce loisir qui est
aussi un sport ça n'est évidemment que
partie remise
tennis pour les adieux de yannick noah
que nous retrouvons en direct dans un
instant de tel-aviv
l'équipe de france a repris sa place
dans le groupe mondial de la coupe davis
est bas israël 3-0 laurent frédéric
bollée petite fête mais grande joie
l'équipe de france de tennis retrouvera
la saison prochaine le groupe mondial de
la coupe davis petite fête mais gros
pincement au coeur yannick noah quitte
son poste de capitaine il avait commencé
contre israël il y a huit ans il termine
aujourd'hui face au même adversaire et
toujours victorieusement guillaume raoux
ex associé à jérôme golmard en face il y
à la paire ehrlich berre
elle ne va pas peser bien lourd une
formalité donc pour le double français
même en ce jour triste ou noah s'en va
c'est triste mais bon ça ça continue
quand il dit que nous suivons de loin je
suis surtout sur un de très près on peut
lui faire confiance
en attendant après les deux points de
victoire hier c'est le troisième
aujourd'hui le double se concluent bien
pauvrement pour les italiens une
victoire en trois sets secs en un peu
plus d'une heure et demie noah peut
partir l'esprit tranquille
bonsoir vous êtes encore direct je le
disais de tel aviv
il ne pouvait en être autrement c'est
donc sur une victoire
une de plus j'ai envie de dire que vous
faites vos adieux vous avez la gorge
nouée peut-être un peu le vertige alors
que tout à l'heure vous étiez ovationné
on a vu sur les images
oui oui c'est vrai que ça m'a touché
d'être ovationné par au moins 25 faire
ça pour mes adieux mais disons que non
non c'était bon je crois que c'est un
moment qu'il fallait passer à partir moi
j'avais décidé de partir bon c'est vrai
que dix pendant cette semaine c'était un
petit peu particulier les émotions un
petit peu particulière et les joueurs
m'ont offert un cadeau fantastique en
gagnant ce match voilà c'est le plus
beau cadeau qui pouvait m'offrir
maintenant je repasse le bébé a dit
forget qui va faire très bien le boulot
justement on reviendra d'ailleurs sur
guy forget mais on a vraiment
l'impression que c'est votre candidat
est votre successeur pour quelle raison
en disant que c'est le candidat de toute
la famille du tennis français quoi guy a
été a été membre des équipes
victorieuses en coupe davis que ce soit
91 ans 96 en tant que joueur est bon
bien naturellement c'est naturellement
que tous les joueurs que moi que le tout
l'entourage a décidé que guy devait
prendre l'équipe en main et je bon je
suis content de pouvoir lui donner une
équipe en première division en pleine
forme alors que yannick noah ou vous
êtes pratiquement pas exprimé depuis
votre décision surprise de quitter vos
fonctions de capitaine de l'équipe de
france
question très simple parce que la
fédération a été étonné est-ce qu'elle a
cherché à vous retenir
vous savez ça fait ça fait à peu près ça
à faire 26 ou 27 ans que je travaille en
tant que joueur entend capitale avec la
fédération alors c'est sûr quand on a
des liens il ya des liens qui se créent
avec avec des gens au sein de la
fédération des entraîneurs mais bon
c'est un c'est juste que j'ai décidé de
ne plus être capitaine bon ben j'ai plus
est ce ce rôle là mais bon ça n'empêche
que nous avons depuis tout ce temps là
créer des liens que ce soit avec les
joueurs ou des gens de la fédération qui
sont des biens qui vont bien au delà du
jeu ben on continuera à se voir mais bon
je serai plus le patron quoi avec le
président vous vous êtes parlé avec
christian bîmes vous vous êtes
rencontrés
non non il ya quelques peu c'est clair
en tout cas ça c'est très clair il ya
quelques mois sur ce plateau même vous
disiez votre projet de prendre en charge
la formation des jeunes
c'est un projet qui vous tenait vraiment
à coeur et au fond est-ce que vous
partez parce que la fédération nous a
pas donné tous les moyens
non j'ai vraiment bon depuis quelques
mois je n'ai eu aucun problème avec la
fédération on était sur la même longueur
d'onde
si j'ai pris cette décision c'est une
décision qui était complètement
personnel j'ai envie de passer plus de
temps avec mémorial et les grands qui
ont 13 et 12 ans bon ben c'est un âge où
papa doit être là un peu plus souvent et
et ça m'arrange bien je vais passer du
temps mais que je j'ai pris cette
décision de gaieté de coeur il n'y a pas
de de sentiments ou de mélancolie ou de
regret
ou de ou de revanche par rapport à la
fédération la fédération était prêt à me
proposer ce que je voulais il se trouve
que j'avais pas vraiment le temps
matériel et on verra dans quelques
années quand si j'ai un peu plus de
temps si on veut toujours de moi aura
sûrement toujours de vous merci yannick
noah d'avoir répondu à nos questions en
direct donc de tel-aviv aux états unis
pour la cinquième édition de la course
du monde en solitaire avec escales 14
bateaux sur le départ deux autres les
rejoindront plus tard
prochaine escale le cap en afrique du
sud ambiance avant ce périple de douze
mille kilomètres comme vous voyez sur
ces images
beaucoup de bateaux pour accompagner le
départ de cette course avant le défilé
géant demain sur les champs elysées qui
doit a rassemblé plus de deux mille
voitures qui ont marqué le siècle les
derniers instants sous la pluie au
volant les collectionneurs de ces
automobiles dans certaines datent
d'avant le début du siècle et rick bass
you and b tulard des voitures les plus
anciennes comme cette vis-à-vis de de
dion bouton fabriqué en 1901 à puteaux
au plus luxueuses comme cette excalibur
elles sont plus de 2000 à se préparer
pour la grande parade leurs
propriétaires les ont bichonné pendant
des années pour les montres et ils sont
venus de la france entière et bien
souvent d'un peu plus loin
je viens de bruxelles en direct à
l'autoroute avec cette voiture
vous savez quelle moyenne à peu près du
90 l'hippodrome de longchamp était cet
après midi le rendez vous de la grande
famille des collectionneurs le
propriétaire de cette lagonda 1932 lui
est un amoureux des belles anglaises et
j'en sais rien esthétique des voitures
qui m'intéresse c'est un bel objet
et ici se trouve tout ce qui a été
construit de plus fou pendant ce siècle
même cette petite mais cherche mythe de
1958 avant gardiste mais tellement
moderne
c'est une voiture qui correspondent à un
besoin de l'époque qui après la guerre
il ya pas beaucoup de pièces
quand c'est un parti des pièces d'avions
mais cherche mythe dernier geste d'amour
avant de quitter sa voiture et de la
retrouver demain à l'aube avant le
défilé événement musical à bercy tout à
l'heure avec sur la même scène les
ténors du rail rachète à khaled et
faudel la méga concert pour cette
musique qui s'adresse à un public de
plus en plus large
un spectacle baptisé 1 2 3 soleil
caroline laudrin eric de l'agneau au
départ c'est un pari organiser un
concert avec trois grands noms du rail
comme avec les ténors du classique
les élus racheta khaled et faudel
détroit il est le plus jeune né en
france il a appris le rail avec sa grand
mère en algérie
petit faudel considérer khaled comme son
idole il ya cinq ans il chantait pour la
première fois ensemble
15 ans c'est même passer à la télé et
tout et j'étais fier quoi je chantais
dollars je marchais dans ma cité j'ai
fait c'était content quoi je me suis dis
bah tiens et si si si à des grands
frères comme ça qu'ils aident les petits
français bien franchi thalys étaient
remarqués en 85
il interprétait douce france de charles
trenet un message d'amertume mais des
d'humour né à oran il a grandi avec le
rail il a traversé les périodes techno
punk aujourd'hui ce serait plutôt du
rock teinté de rythmes orientaux
pour certains le concert de ces trois là
est un drôle de mariage et j'ai tendance
à diamant on n'a aucune activité c'est
ça qui fait le leur mais l'intérêt de ce
spectacle c'est à dire que il ya trois
individus qui sont probablement
différents qui font quelque chose et qui
chacun apporte une pierre à l'édifice
pour la fête du rail il fallait bien ça
soixante huit musiciens dont les
célèbres violence égyptiens double
caleçon
ils chanteront seul à 2 à 3 ce sera leur
façon à eux de parler de l'algérie car
finalement une chance au bon bien tous
les discours
il me rejoignent maintenant en direct de
bercy tout près de la scène à quelques
minutes du cancer du concert antoine
cormery c'est donc la grande fête du
rail c'est un peu là la reconnaissance
de cette musique venue d'algérie
mais oui c'est vrai qu'il ya dix ans
quand on a commencé à entendre les
premiers accords de rails en france on
n'imaginais pas qu'un jour on remplit
remercier pourtant vous le voyez c'est
plein 16000 personnes avec l affiche
trois maîtres du genre il y a faudel il
ya rachida et pilliard à l'aide qui est
sans doute celui qui a le plus contribué
à rendre cette musique populaire en
france
une musique qui rassemble donc bien
au-delà de la communauté algérienne à
qui elle était destinée initialement
rachita nous confier tout à l'heure que
c'était pour lui un beau signe
d'intégration dans la société française
on peut ajouter aussi que c'est d'une
certaine manière un un pied de nez aux
extrémistes qui de l'autre côté de la
méditerranée et bien attendre de faire
taire y compris dans le sang les
chanteurs de raï et la liberté qu'ils
défendent
on l'a dit bercy affiche donc complet
pour cette soirée exceptionnelle qui
j'imagine réserve plein de surprises
bah oui il va y avoir beaucoup
d'ambiance parce que c'est une musique
très entraînante le rail et puis et puis
il faut s'attendre à une grande
diversité pour preuve de cette diversité
c'est avec une chanson de claude
françois que l'on terminera ce concert
tout à l'heure vers 22h30
ça s'appelle comme d'habitude c'est
connu de tous mais c'est vrai qu'il faut
rappeler que claude françois lui aussi
venait de l'autre côté de la
méditerranée merci antoine nous allons
tout de suite rejoindre pas très loin de
vous dans les coulisses khaled
bonsoir soit l'ambiance monte à quelques
minutes de votre entrée en scène au
départ j'ai envie de dire que l'
aventure n'était pas évidente pour vous
est-ce que le pari est déjà gagné
j'espère et je pense que le pari est
déjà gagné
quand paul surtout là quand on se réunit
les trois qui nous qui faisons des
choses différentes différemment et
là je travaille plus et le pari gagné
voilà comblé parce que vous avez peur
d'entrer en scène c'est la caméra l'a
toujours dit le tract pourra toujours
j'ai surtout la bercy pour moi c'est pas
que la première fois que je me produis
fait j'en ai fait des dieux avec mylène
mylène ou d'autres est hélas faire une
soirée quasiment rails avec un mélange
des cordes des égyptiens et des cordes
européens et tout ce qui est puis vivre
tout ce qui est guitares rock américain
vraiment ce beau mélange cocon a voulu
faire rassembler tout ce monde et
montrer qu'on peut le faire et montrer
que la musique c'est quelque chose de
fabuleux c'est quelque chose de beau
c'est quelque chose qui nous fait
oublier pas mal de choses alors
justement khaled pour tous ceux qui
n'auront pas la chance d'être sur place
faites nous un peu partagé l'amour du
rail vous dites que vous les coudes pour
l'écouter il faut s'enivrer du parfum
des femmes dévoilées c'est à dire assez
joli quand même c'est beau non mais
c'est vrai qu'elle perd 100 dollars
tenir sans être dans les dancings des
banlieues de mais je pense que chaque
pays il a sont parfois je pense vu j'ai
vu presque pas le monde entier chaque
pays a son parfum alors son livre eydap
de parfum de soleil c'est comme on a
pris le titre d'aujourd'hui elle 2 3
soleil à meknès alors ça veut dire yat
il ya trois trois jeunes garçons qui qui
donne de l'amour et qui suivent qui sont
libres avec aussi ce public qui est là à
côté de vous et et qui sont libres avec
la musique et qui ramène le parfum de
l'afrique du nord servir g n du sonnet
voilà merci merci khaled est excellent
spectacle j'en suis sûr merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
nafi beaucoup les plus grands
paysagistes du monde entier ont créé une
trentaine de jardins pour le festival de
chooz - une manifestation qui attire
plus de cent cinquante mille visiteurs
thomas senécal et valérie guiton
les jardins de chaumont c'est d'abord
une musique la musique des gouttes d'eau
qui rythme la visite
cette année le thème du festival est
celui des ricochets à l'ombre de ce
château du xvème siècle l'eau fait la
joie des visiteurs en culottes courtes
nous on voit plein de choses qu'on voit
pas habituellement c'est pas commencé et
c'est vrai qu'il ya un peu de tout dans
ces jardins expérimentaux dupont
mystérieux assez drôle de pièges à eau
les enfants vont de découverte en
découverte de paula et un souci les
graines noires qui se mange d'accord et
c'est bon vous risquez plus gros parce
que là c'est trop petit pour le vote
tournesol ou héliotrope ipomées ou
dahlia le plaisir des sens est partout
mais le festival cherche aussi à
inspirer les jardiniers les plus avertis
allongez-vous au piquet nous des idées
donc quand on vous fait une idée c'est
génial pour nous puisque ça nous oblige
immédiatement à la remplacer par une
nouvelle pour la gare plus des idées de
jeu les enfants ne manquent pas et une
fois la visite terminée ils sont
unanimes chaumont c'est encore plus beau
qu'un parc d'attractions c'est se
termine ce journal je vous en rappelle
les principaux titres deuxième suspect
interpellé dans la sphère du meurtre du
petit adrien après les aveux hier d'un
marginal les deux hommes vont être mis
en examen
autres l'utilisation des mines
antipersonnel les pyramides de
l'indignation des montagnes de
chaussures dans une douzaine de villes
en france à l aps d'handicap
international dans un instant la météo
présentée par nathalie rihouet 20h50 un
grand show tout le monde chante le
salvador 23h05 boxe le service des
sports de france bis rue là vous donne
rendez vous en direct pour le
championnat d'europe de poids mouche
l'erreur 25 journal de la nuit est
présenté par bruno roger-petit de mama
ça c'est ou café catherine ceylac reçoit
danielle darrieux et dominique lavanant
le mam évident polémique elisabeth
guigou sera injecté de michèle cotta
je retrouve dès 13h merci de votre
attention est excellente en soirée sur
trois jours
je